le plan fouchet en 61 était un plan
précisément de liant politique et de
défense certains disent général de
gaulle était anti européen il a proposé
le plan le plus ambitieux pour la
politique étrangère la défense et épais
peut-être aussi la culture la justice la
police mais avec une construction à la
base est étatique et pourquoi ça avait
été écarté à l'époque d'abord parce que
il y avait le problème du royaume uni et
qui nos partenaires voulaient que le
royaume uni soit dedans donc aujourd'hui
avec un voile à mais il est parti du web
il voulait surtout je crois qu'ils
soient dedans pour justement porté aussi
sont interdits et américains et puis
deuxièmement sur toutes nos alliés et
continue ses problèmes continuent
aujourd'hui nos alliés ont toujours vous
dit tout ce qui concerne la défense
faire étrangères on peut pas concevoir
des efforts européens qu'ils soient pas
sous l'égide de l'otan ça c'est un
blocage évidemment qui continue
aujourd'hui bien que l'otan n'est plus
du tout le même sens que dans les années
60 ce que donnerait des 60 l'otan
c'était un langage de défense contre
gros l'union soviétique et le fait que
les américains
s'appuyait sur nous en paix en disant
vous allez nous aider dans un grand
ensemble commun qu'on appelle le temps à
lutter contre eux union soviétique
aujourd'hui le problème est un peu
différent mais cela dit ce qui est
intéressant c'est aussi que point pays
comme la pologne certes l'union
soviétique n'est plus l'ennemi mais la
russie si je puis dire ici donc ne jouez
pas
il n'est pas considéré comme un grand
ami voulait donc et n'oubliez pas une
chose c'est que
monsieur kaczinsky qui est le président
de parti droit et justice son frère qui
était président il est mort dans un
accident d'avion lorsque ils ont atterri
pour précisément la cérémonie où on
aurait dû
voir une sorte de pardon pour le
massacre de katyn donc ceci rester dans
la psychologie de la famille qu'elle
suscite
[Musique]